Welcome back.
I'm now going to do a
series of videos on the
trigonometric identities.
So let's just review what
we already know about the
trig function, so let me
just write SOHCAHTOA.
That tells us, and we've
actually extended this with the
unit circle definition, but if
you watch those videos, you'll
realize that the unit circle
definition directly
uses SOHCAHTOA.
So we'll just stick with
SOHCAHTOA because I think it'll
help make some of what we're
about to do seem a little bit
more straightforward and will
kind of verge on the unit
circle definition anyway.
So we know that sine of
theta is equal to opposite
over hypotenuse, right?
So cosine of theta is equal to
adjacent over hypotenuse, and
then the tangent of theta is
equal to opposite
over adjacent.
So let's draw that out
on a right triangle.
We could do this with the
unit circle as well, and
it would make sense.
Let's see if we can find a
relationship between sine,
cosine and tangent.
There's my right triangle.
Let's call this theta.
This is the hypotenuse h.
This is the opposite side,
right, opposite of theta.
This is theta right here.
This is the adjacent
side, right?
Well, what do we know about
the relationship between
the opposite adjacent side
and then the hypotenuse?
What does the Pythagorean
theorem tell us?
Oh, yeah, this side squared
plus this side squared is equal
to the hypotenuse squared,
so we could write that down.
a squared plus o squared is
equal to the hypotenuse
squared, right?
And then this is just an
equation, so if we want to, we
could divide both sides of this
equation by h squared,
and so what do we get?
We get a squared over h squared
plus o squared over h squared
is equal to 1, right?
And then I could rewrite that
as a over h squared plus o
over h squared is equal to 1.
Now, do these look
at all familiar?
Well, we have them here, right?
This is a over h, this is
o over h, so we could
just substitute.
So this is just cosine
of theta squared.
And this is how you
write cosine squared.
You could put a parentheses
around the whole thing and then
square it, but this is just
the notation people use.
Plus opposite over adjacent
squared, so that's sine theta
squared is equal to 1.
So that's our first
trig identity.
So if you know the sine of
theta, it's very easy to figure
out the cosine of theta, right?
You could just solve
this equation.
If I know that the--
I don't know.
Let's say I know that the
sine of theta is 1/2, right?
Then what is the
cosine of theta?
The cosine of theta is what?
Well, I know the sine of
theta is 1/2, right?
So I would say cosine squared
of theta plus sine of theta
is 1/2, so 1/2 squared
is equal to 1, right?
So cosine squared theta
plus 1/4 is equal to 1.
So we have cosine squared theta
is equal to 3/4, or cosine of
theta would be the square
root of this, right?
We just take the square
root of both sides.
It would be the
square root of 3/2.
And you probably remember that
from our whole presentation
on the 30-60-90 triangle.
So I just wanted to show you
a use of this trig identity
that's usually written
sine squared plus cosine
squared is equal to 1.
So let's extend that
one a little bit.
Let's just play with the ratios
and see what else we can--
other identities
we can discover.
Whoops!
Clear image, invert colors.
So we know that sine squared
theta plus cosine squared
theta is equal to 1.
The one thing we could do is we
could divide both sides of this
equation by cosine squared of
theta, and let's just see what
happens when we do that.
So if we say cosine
squared theta, right?
You have to distribute
across both terms.
Cosine squared of theta, and
then cosine squared of theta.
Well, what's sine squared theta
over cosine squared theta?
That's the same thing as sine
of theta over cosine of theta
squared plus this is 1 over
cosine theta squared, right?
I mean, 1 squared is 1,
so I just rewrote it.
So sine over cosine theta, I
think we learned that already.
That's just the
tangent of theta.
And in case you actually
haven't learned that already,
think about it this way.
Sine is opposite over
the hypotenuse, right?
So that's opposite
over hypotenuse.
And then cosine is
adjacent over hypotenuse.
So adjacent over hypotenuse.
So then that equals opposite
over hypotenuse times
hypotenuse over
adjacent, right?
Just dividing by a fraction is
the same thing as multiplying
by its reciprocal.
That's all I did.
And that equals opposite
over adjacent, right?
So that just says sine of
theta over cosine of theta is
equal to tangent of theta.
So sine squared theta over
cosine squared theta is tan
squared theta, then plus 1 is
1 over cosine theta squared.
And now I'm going to introduce
a new trig ratio, it's really
just 1 over cosine theta.
So 1 over cosine theta-- and
I'm going to summarize this at
the end, just so it's not too
confusing-- is actually
the secant of theta.
And this is just
another ratio, right?
The secant of theta, instead of
being the adjacent over the
hypotenuse, would be the
hypotenuse over the
adjacent, right?
It's just 1 over cosine theta.
Nothing fancy here.
So secant of theta.
So that equals secant
squared of theta.
I know it can be a little
overwhelming initially, just
because I'm, you know, throwing
out all these new terms, secant
is 1 over cosine theta, but
once you just play around with
these enough and get familiar
with the terms, it'll make
sense, and it'll be a little
more natural to you.
So this could be-- you
could view this as
another trig identity.
And actually, I don't
even remember if I've
taught it already.
I mean, you could view this as
a trig identity, although
that's almost definitional.
And then, of course, you can--
in case I haven't done it
already, you now know that sine
of theta over cosine of theta
is equal to tangent of theta.
And that's right here
with, I guess you could
say, the proof of it.
So let me keep introducing you
to more things, and if this is
really daunting, maybe you
just can rewatch it, and
hopefully, it'll make sense.
Let me see, clear image.
So what have we learned so far?
We learned that sine squared
theta plus cosine squared
theta is equal to 1.
We learned that sine of theta
over cosine of theta is
equal to tangent of theta.
We learned that the tangent
squared of theta plus 1 is
equal to the secant of theta.
And here, let me actually
write this definition down.
The secant of theta-- oops,
is equal to the secant
squared of theta, sorry.
And the secant of theta is
just 1 over cosine of theta.
This is something you really
should just memorize, that
secant is 1 over cosine.
And if you're wondering what 1
over sine is, 1 over sine of
theta, it's the cosecant-- the
abbreviation is csc-- of theta.
And if you're wondering what
1 over the tangent is,
it's the cotangent.
And you just might want
to memorize these.
And this often confuses me,
that 1 over the cosine is the
secant, but 1 over the sine is
the cosecant, so it's kind of
almost the opposite, right?
1 over the sine has a co in
it, while 1 over the cosine
doesn't have the co in it.
So that might help
you remember things.
So I think that's all
I have time for now.
In the next presentation, I'm
going to introduce you to a
couple more trig identities.
See you soon.